I see this side too.
There's another dark side of the marketplace though.
You know,
I think the news nowadays,
you know,
makes a lot of money on clickbait and,
and so you,
you now have companies,
whether it's the Huffington Post or CNN or whatever who are less interested.
It seems an objective reporting of the news and way more interested in
generating clicks.
Did you feel fucking Newsweek title the,
that they put out about Trump and the Nazis like stealing Christmas?
Did you see?
There you go.
That's a classic seed can find it.
What is that?
I'm already intrigued.
You know the news,
the world is such a public infotainment.
That's a tragedy.
Newsweek,
which you would always say there compete met.
They have to compete.
That's what it is.
But you'd always think they're measured.
They're intelligent.
This is Newsweek.
They get respected when,
when Chris Rock Dep,
when Chris was working on a bit how Trump and the Nazi stole Christmas to
promote white nationalism.
Hey,
fucking slow down.
Yeah.
This is just,
is there,
you're going to get Caitlyn Jenner elected president if you keep this shit up.
Exactly.
Like you have to understand what's happening here.
People are going to go nuts.
The media's approval rating the opposite according to some polls,
the media,
his approval rating is in the single digits and I think they deserve it.
I really do.
I,
um,
am not nearly as cynical as a lot of people,
but as I get older and I see how her responsible,
a lot of the news is how much money there is to be made by just,
just hinting or sort of,
you know,
associating somebody's name with something kind of volatile shore product of
their environment.
Like they're dealing with what gets a response and when it gets clicks.
So all good questions.
Societies are the ones who are telling them to do this.
They're not just making this shit up.
That's right.
Right?
They're like,
well,
if we,
if we say Trump,
the Nazi stole Christmas,
how many clicks are going to get?
See,
but this is what they're doing is they're being more inclusive.
Hold on.
They're being disingenuous here in this article.
Scroll up a little bit because here's one of the things it says.
It says,
Donald Trump wants America to thank,
he reinvented Christmas.
We can say merry Christmas again.
He has said on numerous occasions,
both during the campaign of president and presidency,
Christmases back better than ever before.
He told supporters month before the Christmas season,
fuck he is doing what a guy who's very persuasive does to try to get people on
his camp.
He's a falcon.
Politicians got a sense of humor,
but it's not even true,
but what,
what?
What he's doing here is not even true because he in the past did a lot of tweets
about happy holidays,
happy.
I like people pulled them up that he used to say happy holidays all the time,
like really recently was tweeting happy holidays and then the idea that Obama
never said merry Christmas is 100% horseshit.
There's a whole video of Obama saying merry Christmas,
Merry Chris was over and it was wrong.
The Marianists miss nothing wrong with it.
This idea is he's trying to sell people on the idea that you,
your Christian values have been suppressed by this mediocre left wing government
and he's stepping in here to make America great again.
It's all a hustle,
but it's not white nationalists and Nazis.
Like you can't say Nazis.
The problem is when you say that you leave the word Nazi loses its fucking
meaning.
Yeah.
They're irresponsible journalists.
They're not journalists.
They're irresponsible.
Yeah.
What he's doing is he's being a fucking politician.
He's been a weasel.
He's trying to pretend that Christmas was never,
we never,
we never had Christmas before.
We're going to have Christmas now and all the dopes,
all the yokels,
but
you know,
this guy's out there with make America great again.
Tattoos.
You just understand this.
This is real.
Like there's people with red hat tattoos that say,
make America great again on there's dummies every fucking quadrant of this
earth,
but do you know that?
I have to say that the mainstream media,
and I'm,
I know I'd never been a fan of Trump,
but the way they treat him with this kind of stuff that I constantly hear this
petty shit.
The way it drinks water and stuff.
It's funny,
it's made me more sympathetic.
But when you drink water,
drink water like this
12 guys,
it's fucking,
when you drink 12 diet cokes might be true or I don't believe it.
You know,
I don't know what to believe anymore.
That's the other problem.
There's another bunch of,
cause he quotes series of quotes from him from back in the day saying,
why would you drink that coke and drink diet coke?
People drink diet coke or all salt fat diet coke makes you fat.
It's been proven.
There's a whole series of tweets.
Like he might've just forgot he made those tweets.
Well he shred.
It just doesn't give a fuck.
Yeah,
but I think that,
you know,
first of all,
he as a president,
here's a weird one,
there was a terror attack that was thwarted by the FBI in San Francisco.
You didn't hear a God damn peep about it because he's against the FBI because of
this.
All this investigation shit.
So the president in the United States didn't,
it didn't like congratulate the FBI,
didn't tell the American people that the FBI had done a great job at the FBI.
I know,
I know about the terrorist attack.
I read boarded a legitimate terrorists attacked and this is all this whole make
America great again.
Stuff,
right?
If you want to stop the terrorists,
he is a political point.
He avoided this crazy guy is terrible.
Raj Arrest Man,
suspected of plotting isis inspired Christmas terror attack in San Francisco.
It was a marine who would,
you know,
started going crazy.
Yeah.
Well it's just very handy.
It's very crazy.
And how about he started to,
they,
they caught him.
He started to like,
like isis post on Facebook and then he reached out to isis and went,
hey,
look into complete this mission.
How do I get ahold of the guns and bullets?
Nicest.
Like homeboy,
if you have to ask for the gear,
might not be for you.
Like what the fuck?
They're dumb.
I go meet us on the dock where the asshole get out of here man.
Y'All clog on your truck as you pull up.
Make it super obvious.
Every time.
I've been pier 39 and I've been there every time I go to San Francisco,
I always think that I'm always like,
I don't think like,
damn that's a lot of people though have been making this comment on why did the
president not discussed this?
Like well this is something that like when you address the nation,
you have to talk about it.
And even if he's in some sort of a squabble with one aspect of the FBI,
you have to recognize that they did their job here.
This is why they're doing a great job.
Yeah.
And this is why they're important.
Like the literally protected American lives and he's not mentioning it bullshit
that day.
Do when they're saying things like how Trump stole Christmas with white
nationalists and Nazis,
that petty,
that kind of petty shit and forces his petty.
Yup.
That's in a way of real news.
And they go at it.
They go at each other back and forth and nothing gets done.
So when these,
to grow the fuck up and it should be the president,
but he will weak.
She needs to grow the fuck up too.
You can't say things like that.
That's silly.
We,
we should be able to rely on the mainstream news,
and I know I'm going to get a lot emails about the main Eddie Bravo was calling
you right now,
but we should be a little bit,
we should rely on them to at least report the facts,
at least objective facts.
That was the whole point of journalism.
They were the fourth estate they keep,
they keep power in line.
They hold,
they speak truth to power.
That's the whole idea.
In a democracy,
you need a free press.
You need,
but now with money ratings,
it has corrupted.
Well.